John sandal left us a message on
Facebook and he said I'd love to hear
mr. Truby on the differences between
structuring episodes for network / cable
versus webisodes is the latter webisode
is often much shorter merely a smaller
version of the former or are there any
inherent formal differences that's a
really good question because it gets to
the heart of how these two different
story mediums work one of the biggest
mistakes that writers make is they think
if they're writing webisodes which which
are essentially stories on the Internet
that it's simply you simply take a say a
TV episode and cut it into parts
so if a TV episode is 44 minutes and you
know you're your standard webisode is
five minutes long you just cut that into
eight plus pieces and you've got your
you've got eight episodes of your
webisode this is a very bad idea because
what that means is the the writer
doesn't understand these are two
fundamentally different kinds of Story
mediums and that means different use of
character different use of plot
different use of dialogue different use
of genre now we literally saw this
happen a few years ago which is when the
creators of thirtysomething did a show
called quarter life and it was their
background was television they're you
know historically major figures in
television and then they were writing
these webisodes well the problem is they
still had the TV mind and so they
constructed these webisodes as parts of
simply parts of one episode of
television and that meant that they were
doing television on the web well the web
is a different story medium you can't
just cut up TV
make those the webisodes because that
you're not taking advantage of the
unique medium that the internet gives
you so that's why it's very important
when you're thinking about writing
webisodes and by the way I strongly
recommend that people move into this
area because you can create work that
will be seen right and show your talent
and it's a new way of having a calling
card and breaking in but you will have
to write these things so that you are
taking advantage of the internet medium
not to television media and so that
means fewer characters right you're
gonna have a much less complicated story
weave than you will in television it's
still a serial right so we'll be
cross-cutting between different desire
lines but far fewer of them right it
also means that you're the story world
is much more constricted television
sword-worlds now immense one of the
major developments in television over
the last 10 years the complexity and
scope of the story world well with
webisodes much smaller and so in the
original creation of the show you've got
to be able to essentially create story
with very few characters in a very small
space literally a very small space
that's hard to do then this is why it
dictates another particular choice this
is why the vast majority of webisodes or
comedies because if you have talent
creating comedy it's one that you can do
with very few characters in a small
physical space with very few storylines
and you could do it fairly cheaply so
again the trick is study the medium
figure out what are the strengths of
that medium and then write a story a
unique story that plays up those
you